We have said that the Bernoulli
process is the simplest
stochastic processes there is.
But what is a stochastic
process anyway?
A stochastic process
can be thought
of as a sequence of
random variables.
Now, how is this different
from what we have doing before,
where we have dealt with
multiple random variables?
Well, one difference
is that here we're
talking about an infinite
sequence of random variables.
And that complicates
things to a certain extent.
Now, what does it take to
describe a stochastic process?
We should specify the
properties of each one
of those random variables.
For example, we might be
interested in the mean,
variance, or PMF of
those random variables.
For the case of the
Bernoulli process,
this would be easy to do.
We know what the
expected value is.
We have a formula
for the variance.
And we have a fairly simple PMF.
There's probability p that X
is equal to 1 and probability 1
minus p that X equals to 0.
But this is not enough.
We also need to know how the
different random variables are
related to each other.
And this is done by specifying,
directly or indirectly,
the joint distribution,
the joint PMF or PDF,
of the random
variables involved.
And because we have an infinite
number of random variables,
it's not enough to
do this, let's say,
for the first n of them.
We need to be able to specify
this joint distribution
no matter what the number n is.
For the case of the
Bernoulli process,
we have specified this joint
PMF in an indirect way,
because we have said that
the random variables are
independent of each other.
So the joint factors as a
product of the marginals.
And we already know
what the marginals are.
So we do, indeed, have a
specification of the joint PMF,
and we have that
for all values of n.
Of course, for more complicated
stochastic processes,
this calculation might be
somewhat more difficult.
Now, there is a second view
of a stochastic process
which rests on the following.
It's not just a collection
of random variables,
but they are a
collection that's indexed
by an index that
keeps increasing.
And quite often, we think of
this index as corresponding
to time.
And so we have a
mental picture that
involves a process that
keeps evolving in time.
What is this picture?
This picture is
best developed if we
think in terms of
the sample space.
Although we have an infinite
sequence of random variables,
we are dealing with
a single experiment.
And that single
experiment runs in time.
And when we carry
out the experiment,
we might to get an outcome
such as the following.
For the Bernoulli process, we
might get a 0, 0, 1, 0, 1, 1,
0, and so on.
And we continue.
So an infinite
sequence of that kind
is one possible outcome of this
infinitely long experiment,
one particular outcome of
the stochastic process.
If we carry out the
process once more,
we might get a
different outcome.
For example, we might get a 0,
1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 1, 1, and so on,
and continuing.
And in general, any time
function of this kind
is one possible outcome
of the experiment.
Overall, the sample space
that we're dealing with
is the set of all infinite
sequences of 0s and 1s.
This point of view
emphasizes the fact
that we have a phenomenon
that evolves over time
and can be used to
answer questions that
have to do with the long-term
evolution of this process.
Here's one particular
kind of question
we might want one answer.
What is the probability that all
of the Xi's turn out to be 1?
Notice that this is an event
that involves all of the Xi's
not just a finite
number of them.
So this is not a
probability that we
can calculate right away
by using this joint pmf.
We need to do a
little more work.
What is the work
that we want to do?
Instead of calculating
this quantity,
we will calculate a
somewhat related quantity.
Let us look at the
event that the first n
results were equal to 1.
How is this event
related to this event?
Well, this event here implies
that this event has happened.
So this is a smaller event.
This is more difficult
to obtain than this one.
And this gives us an inequality
for the probabilities
that go this way.
Now, we know that
this probability
is equal to p to the n.
And this inequality
here is true for all n.
No matter how large n
we take, this quantity
is smaller than that.
But now, since p has been
assumed to be less than 1,
when we take n
larger and larger,
this number becomes
arbitrarily small.
So this quantity is
less than or equal
to an arbitrarily small number.
So this quantity can
only be equal to 0.
And this is a simple example
of how we calculate properties
of the stochastic process as it
evolves over the infinite time
horizon and how we can
sometimes calculate them using
these so-called finite
dimensional joint probabilities
that tell us what
the process is doing
over a finite amount of time.
Throughout, we will sometimes
view stochastic processes
in this manner, in terms of
probability distributions.
But sometimes we will
also want to reason
in terms of the behavior
of the stochastic process
as a time function, as a
process that evolves in time.